hu à pouvoir se marier enfin c'est ce
que célébré aux efforts et en couleurs
c'est à dire aux festivités annuelles de
la fierté à taïwan
l'empereur du mariage des personnes de
même sexe dans l'île autorisée depuis
mai dernier
je suis très heureuse qu'il y est un
monde dit elle
cela montre que l'adoption de la loi
encourage de plus en plus les gens à se
tenir debout
elle se réjouit aussi de voir des
participants de partout sur la planète
des étrangers qui espère que le cas de
taiwan fera boule de neige qu'il aura un
effet domino chez eux
ce militant de la malaisie explique qu
on en est encore loin
qu'il y ait encore beaucoup de
discriminations dans son pm à taiwan en
2010 est le plus haut tribunal du pays
avait statué que l'interdiction du
mariage gay était inconstitutionnelle il
avait donné deux ans au parlement pour
modifier la loi en prévenant que faute
d'action ce mariage de viendrait de
toute façon réalité après cette date
butoir
le thème de la fierté cette année c'est
ensemble faisons en sorte que taiwan
soit meilleure nation un appel au
rassemblement à la bonne entente pour
faire comprendre à tout le monde que les
homosexuels sont leurs voisins leurs
familles leurs amis dit cette militante
car la population taiwanaise est divisée
sur le mariage gay une forte majorité de
résidants de nil s'étaient prononcés
contre par référendum l'an dernier ici à
libérer radio canada taipei